landon
is with us landon is in memphis hi
landon how are you
hey how's it going dave i appreciate you
taking my call sure how can i help
uh so i'm 24 my wife is 22 and she just
started working
and we're both working full time now and
we want to pay our house off for the
next 17 months
wow i love you guys i know that you now
i know that you say that
you should take your foot off the gas
just a little bit and do some things
after you pay off your debt so we don't
have any debt so we just
really hate our house payments so much
that we just want to kind of
kill it and get it over with and so
after we do that our goal is to save
up for some rental properties and
potentially build a
real estate portfolio and you know go
from there
and all in all cash right of course yes
sir yeah man you're on
wow i love you you're awesome so my
question is after pay our house off
and start saving up for real estate how
aggressive should we be
in in building our real estate portfolio
because if it was up to me and my wife
would do it too
because she's 22. when she's 32 maybe
not so much
she'll get tired of your butt exactly
and so
you know how aggressive should we be to
saving up and paying cash for real
estate
um you know and still enjoy
some of you know the money i got to tell
you man i really like you i was you when
i was 24. you're incredible
uh and so i can tell you this you're
going to kill your wife okay
don't kill your wife you're going to
kill her enthusiasm for this because you
would
i i'm all the way to the wall man you
put everything on the wall don't you you
don't hold anything back pedal to the
metal go for it
and uh you know she's going to be on
beans and rice until you have two
million dollars in real estate
and she'll start to hate me and you okay
let's not do that exactly right
yeah so that's that's what i would have
done it's exactly how i'm wired and the
mistakes i made in my marriage when i
was your age
so i get to save you from me okay
so so anyway the um
what we'll do is you'll be at baby step
seven when your home's paid off
right right very well done you guys are
studs
breathe twice okay now
look at your household income what's
your household income at that point
so take home this year we'll take home
about 120 next year we'll take home
about 150.
good for you and so out of that we're
going to be having huge piles of cash to
buy real estate with
and the only question is how intense and
are we in agreement on what the question
is
are you asking me no is that what you're
asking me
yes sir that's right how aggressive
should we be what kind of time i want
you to take a percentage of your budget
in addition to taxes in addition to
tithe if you're an evangelical christian
like me you tithe
okay in addition to those two things
take a percentage of your income
to enjoy okay
and a percentage to invest and an
additional
percentage for outrageous generosity
i don't care what the percentages are
but if generosity and enjoyment
are zero and investing is a hundred
percent you're going to blow your wife
up
right and your life so
even if you just add additional five
percent for generosity
and ten percent for enjoyment you get to
buy the couch the car the trip
the whatever the thingy is that lets a
little steam off
and then you can put still the lion's
share towards investing
but this is the point that you should
kind of smooth things out just a little
bit
with a little let you know you don't use
gazelle intensity at baby step seven
right so some percentage for enjoyment
and by the way before you state the
percentage
ask her what it is yes sir
and uh then probably go with her answer
okay and because she's not gonna she's
not gonna say 70 percent
for enjoyment no yeah i'll just tell you
now she's going to want to buckle down
and get it
you know put pedal to the metal that's
not see the thing you're doing here the
problem is you almost said get it over
with you don't get this over with
because the program we're putting in
here is the rhythm of the rest of your
life
right you don't get over you don't get
over generosity you don't get over
investing right you never get enough to
do all these things
you can always do more so it's not like
the other baby steps where you can check
a box
we're now in the rhythm of the journey
rather than the task
when you get baby step seven so that's
why these percentages this is the same
exact thing i do when i'm meeting with
an nfl player who's making 10 million
a year because their average career is
3.2 years
nfl stands for not for long and we try
to explain to them during this time you
need to bank a bunch of this you need to
have some enjoyment
but too many of these guys enjoy it all
and then they have nothing when they
come out of the league
so don't enjoy it all but don't invest
at all don't give it all
do all three at some percentage that the
three the two of you are in agreement
with
and you're gonna be perfectly safe good
job man well done
this is the dave ramsey show